[Music]
mark's with us in springfield hey mark
welcome to the ramsay show
how you doing dave great man what's up
well i've got a question um i kind of
did some stupid stuff and uh
last year or a little bit over a year
ago i called into one of your other
shows that he's no longer with you so i
don't know if i need to if i can say his
name or not
um
okay well i call it was chris hogan and
uh
he gave me uh ramsay plus for a year
good well then
two days later you guys parted ways
and me and my infinite wisdom said well
this dave ramsey's an idiot i'm not ever
going to do anything with him
so i convinced my wife that dave ramsey
is an idiot
well now here i am a year and a half
later she got to talk to my wife
i don't think that would help him with
what he's now going towards then oh i'm
sorry i've got side currents i got
sidetracked okay
okay so anyway here i am a year and a
half later realized that you know my
infinite wisdom was not really with him
at all and
i need to try and get back
on the dave ramsey program well the
problem is i've convinced my wife that
dave ramsey's an idiot and so now i'm
trying to
fix that and convince her that i was
wrong
and
i just i
i'm not sure that i'm doing a good job
of it um
she had we had one bill that i figured
if we could pay this off you know it
would it would get her to see
what was going on
but
all it did was get her to say well that
means that we can invest this money now
and we've still got 84 000
in debt not including the house
and
i know that we need to get that paid off
before the investing but she's worried
because she's got a lot of medical
issues and she doesn't know that she's
going to be able to live long enough to
be able to see retirement if we don't
start now
um
what's the nature of her medical issues
well she's got
type 1 diabetes
when she's got a history of cancer like
every female in her family has died of
cancer but she does not have cancer
not yet no okay and how old are you but
she's
well i'm 40 and she's well i will be 40
in a couple months and she's 36. okay
well her her thinking she's gonna die
before she has wealth using our system
is asinine
okay she's not gonna die before she has
wealth unless she has a car wreck not
from what you've just described to me
anyway
so that's her saying i don't believe you
that's not a truthful statement that's
hyperbole and drama
that's just her saying you know you've
been wrong so much i don't know which
time you were right that's all she's
saying
that's true what's your income mark
combined income or or sole income
uh we have combined income uh our our
take-home income is just under a hundred
thousand okay so you got plenty of money
you just don't have a system how long
y'all been married
uh well we've been married for
just over a year like a year and a half
but we've been together for eight and a
half years okay all right well now
you're together and now you got to
decide what's the next 20 years look
like
and so
the the thing i i would take dave ramsey
ken coleman chris hogan out of the
equation
i don't think i don't think they're
relevant to your life in in terms of the
actual people involved there that's
we're not relevant the question is
what's the vision yeah for y'all's
future
and i um
i think you sit down and you look out
there into the future
and you say all right let's turn off the
tv
let's set everything aside set all the
bills aside let's set all the worries
about medical aside
and let's say
okay when we're 65
when we're 70
what do we want our life to look like
and write those things down
that's called a vision
okay and get really detailed high-def
television hd
okay
and then the two of you look at that and
and let's talk about that long enough
and don't tell her what her vision is
ask her
what her vision is
and then she needs to ask you and the
two of you talk to talk it through until
you go okay so out of all the things we
wrote down here the most important thing
we're both saying is this and the next
most important thing is this and you say
okay we'd like to have a million dollars
and we'd like to be traveling the world
we'd like to have no debt
that'd be an example okay
when you're when you're 65. i'd like to
have the money to travel and enjoy my
life i don't know if you want to travel
or not i just made that up okay but
whatever it is you write down what we
want to do is okay and then you say all
right now
and then my friend henry cloud says
that's your desired future then you have
to ask yourself what has to be true
that is not true today
for us to be there then
well we got to shed 84 000 worth of debt
we have to start saving money we have to
start living in control and quit
spending like we're in congress
right
that's what has to be true for you to
get to that dream
now what is the method weak next
question is what is the method we use
to get rid of 84 000 in debt quit
spending like we're in congress be in
agreement on our spending uh and be
investing steadily so that we have a
million dollars we can travel the world
we're 65.
and we have no debt
um
what is the easiest method to do that
what's the most proven method to do that
oh there's a thing called financial
peace university
we could go through that and watch that
together and see after we watch it if we
think that that is the best way for us
to get to our desired future
10 million people have gone through the
class
okay
10 million people have gone through the
glass
if it was screwing people if we were
ripping people off
somewhere around a million someone would
have said this is a rip-off
we get no complaints about it being
rip-off
the only complaints we get is is the
stuff we tell people to do is hard
but it works
every
time you work it
to the extent you work it so
first you decide where it is you want to
go then you decide how i want to get
there and then you decide who can guide
me the quickest to get on my journey
and i'm convinced that the ramsey
organization as a whole
not me personally but financial peace
university the steps we teach is the
fastest
right way
to become wealthy
and i'll give you another year of ramsay
plus of financial peace university for
you guys to sit down and watch that
together but you can't just do that on
the basis of dave ramsey's a good guy or
dave ramsey he's not a bad guy
dave ramsey's a bad guy that ramsey is a
good guy or i don't like you know i
don't like chris hogan left i don't like
you can't that doesn't decide your
future
that decides dave ramsey's future chris
hogan's future ken coleman's future but
but your future is decided by what you
do
so you got to decide what you're going
to do
and if if i've lost credibility in your
household because hogan left then so be
it it's okay
find you a way though dude
find you a proven path to get there
uh because it didn't happen unless you
guys do it and you do it together